SIERRA: Hey everyone, so just a quick heads
up that this is our last episode of season
4. We will be taking a break for the holidays
to produce an amazing line up for season 5,
so stay tuned for updates, and have a fabulous
end of your year.
DW News: Growing American concerns about the
threats posed by China.
Today: It's a new breed of super fast missiles.
CBN News: It s a hypersonic missile.
Forbes Breaking News: Hypersonic missile.
Fox News: Hypersonic weapon system.
ABC News: Beijing test launched the weapon
this summer, sending it into space and around
the planet.
CNBC Television: We are behind the Chinese,
we are behind the Russians, there s a lot
more work to do on hypersonics.
?ABC News: How would you track it if it were
carrying a nuclear weapon?
SIERRA: Last month, United States General
Mark Milley, the chairman of the U.S. Joint
Chiefs of Staff, held a press conference and
confirmed suspicions that China had tested
a hypersonic missile over the summer. A lot
of the coverage that followed was breathless.
In the confusion, it was easy to imagine futuristic,
superfast missiles that could evade our defenses
and strike without warning. Some compared
the test to a sputnik moment , invoking the
Cold War and its perilous arms races. The
truth is a lot more complex, and many of these
fears may be exaggerated. Still, it was an
exceptional moment, if only because it gave
a new generation a taste of a nuclear danger,
and reminded the world about the fragile system
of mutually assured destruction that has prevented
nuclear war for decades. I m Gabrielle Sierra
and this is Why It Matters. Today, the truth
about hypersonic missiles.
SIERRA: Alright so nuclear weapons are scary
to begin with, and hypersonic missiles with
nuclear warheads sound even scarier. So on
a scale of one to ten, how scared should I
be?
GREGO: So I am not going to tell you how scared
to be. I think a lot of people imagine we
left this nuclear competition behind at the
end of the Cold War. I run into people who
think that all the time.
SIERRA: This is Laura Grego. She is a Stanton
Nuclear Security Fellow at the Laboratory
for Nuclear Security and Policy at MIT.
GREGO: I'm gen X, I grew up in the 80s and
that was front and center. That was our common
culture was like the Soviets and the US, all
of this stuff. And things have changed significantly.
And we've gotten rid of so many nuclear weapons,
but we are entering a dangerous phase again.
And this is not just bilateral, it's trilateral.
There's the US, Russia and China are all modernizing
their nuclear arsenals and nuclear delivery
systems, recapitalizing, rebuilding, building
new different ways to deliver nuclear weapons.
SIERRA: As of 2021, there are roughly 13,150
nuclear warheads on Earth, about 90 percent
of which are owned by Russia and the United
States. That sounds like a lot, and it is,
but thanks to disarmament agreements, the
number is way down from a peak of more than
60,000 in 1986. As Laura noted, the threat
has not disappeared, and Russia, the United
States, and other nuclear players like China
are investing heavily in modernizing their
nuclear arsenals.
SIERRA: Ok let s get more specific. Tell me
about hypersonic weapons.
GREGO: I think the name hypersonic just sounds
really awesome like this is something new,
and the technology isn't new, the dynamics
aren't even all that new. So the name hypersonic
missiles, is a little bit of a red herring
because, "Hypersonic," describes the speed
of something. So hypersonic is five times
the speed of sound. it goes fast, but that's
not special about these missiles. Intercontinental
ballistic missiles go faster than that. For
50 years we've had hypersonic-speed missiles,
so that's not new. When people talk about
hypersonic missiles, really what they're talking
about is missiles that are maneuverable.
SIERRA: To understand why this maneuverability
matters, you have to know how the old technology
works. Meet the Intercontinental Ballistic
Missile, or ICBM, which has dominated nuclear
strategy for decades.
GREGO: So ballistic missiles go up into the
vacuum of space and come down, just like you
throw a rock or you throw a baseball. If you
have a ball that you're throwing and you want
it to go as far as possible, your brain is
going to do this calculation for you and pick
the angle. It's sort of a 45 degree angle
and that's how you're going to get the furthest.
SIERRA: In general, ICBMs follow this same
trajectory. They are launched into the atmosphere
with the same type of rockets we use to launch
satellites.
GREGO: It's just this big powerful rocket
engine, you know, you know, gets things going
up to a high speed. And normally an intercontinental
ballistic missile will launch, it will burn
for three to five minutes to get going up
to high speeds, like seven or eight kilometers
per second. And it will send its payload,
which is for intercontinental ballistic missiles,
it's invariably a nuclear weapon. And it'll
send high up arcing through space. As soon
as a missile burns out, it's not in powered
flight anymore. So it goes up, it'll arch
high up into space, sort of a thousand kilometers
altitude or so, and then come back down on
the other of the earth. So an ICBM's reason
for being is to deliver something from here
to there in 30 to 40 minutes. Once you launch
it, it goes. And you don't recall it. You
don't retarget it. It just ends up where you've
targeted it, 30 minutes later.
SIERRA: Some modern ICBMs have the ability
to alter course a bit on their way back down
to earth, but in general, they always go where
you point them, and you can t change your
mind after launch. They are fast and powerful,
but they are also predictable, and the world
s advanced militaries have gotten really good
at detecting and tracking them. This is where
hypersonic missiles come in.
MOUNT: What most people talk about when they
talk about a hypersonic missile is a hypersonic
glide vehicle. This is a system that is attached
to a normal ballistic missile booster, then
thrown into the atmosphere, it detaches, and
then it glides through the atmosphere maneuvering
in flight at very high speeds.
SIERRA: This is Adam Mount. He is a senior
fellow at the Federation of American Scientists
with a focus on U.S. nuclear weapons policy.
So that the difference between a hypersonic
glide vehicle and a normal ballistic missile
is that a normal ballistic missile is flung
towards its target on a predictable trajectory.
A hypersonic glide vehicle by contrast is
slower because it's having to go through the
atmosphere, but it can also maneuver in the
atmosphere. And so you're not totally sure
when it's fired where it's going to end up.
SIERRA: Countries around the world have been
developing this technology for decades in
different ways. And while the biggest concerns
are related to nuclear security, countries
are also developing non-nuclear hypersonic
missiles for use in battle. The basic appeal
is simple: they re hard to detect, and very
hard to shoot down.
GREGO: The United States missile defenses
and radar systems have been set up to detect
and defend against ballistic missiles, which
are arcing high up and coming back down. So
the radars are sort of curated to look for
things that are coming from that direction.
And so these gliders that are skimming through
the atmosphere literally fly under the radar.
The radars are looking at high altitudes,
and these will come underneath them. So those
radars, yes, they cannot see these because
they're not really designed to.
SIERRA: However, hypersonic missiles aren
t actually invisible . Some experts think
that they could be spotted with current technology,
for example infrared sensors. But they are
a whole lot sneakier than ICBMs. And that
is enough to put militaries on edge.
SIERRA: So can you tell me about the basics
of the recent Chinese weapons tests that prompted
all this worry?
MOUNT: We're still not sure, given unclassified
information, exactly what China tested or
what they intended to test. It's easy to get
alarmed about headlines about hypersonic missiles
specifically because it means that we are
vulnerable to our adversaries. It is never
comfortable to be reminded by that. The public
reports suggest that China tested a missile
system that was capable of, injecting a hypersonic
glide vehicle into low earth orbit. So it
can orbit the earth more or less indefinitely
and then exit that orbit at a time and place
of its choosing. This grants it the capability,
for example, to inject itself into an orbit
that goes over the South Pole and then strikes
at the Continental United States from an unexpected
direction, ?
SIERRA: This particular type of technology,
which puts a hypersonic weapon into orbit,
is called a FOBS, or fractional orbital bombardment
system, more on that later.
GREGO: Ballistic missiles between countries
in the Northern Hemisphere, tend to come up
over the North Pole towards each other, from
China to the US, US to China, between all
three of these countries, they'll come up
northerly. But if you want to get around missile
defenses, you want to confuse them. One way
you can do it is come from an unexpected direction.
So hypersonic missiles come from unexpected
directions, on sort of a small scale, making
maneuvers of thousands of kilometers out of
the direction you expect. But if you put something
in orbit and then deorbit it, you can come
around from a completely different direction,
like from the south, you can come up from
the South Pole. So, that strategy of putting
something into orbit and then bringing it
back down when it's over its target is called
orbital bombardment, or if it doesn't complete
one entire orbit, it'll be a fractional orbital
bombardment system. So what it looked like
China did was put something into orbit and
then deorbit it, and what that something was,
was a hypersonic glide vehicle.
SIERRA: We should note that China s missile
test landed 24 miles off target. And when
asked about the test, Chinese officials stated
it was a routine test of a space vehicle.
Still, the test seemed to combine TWO advanced
missile technologies 1) a hypersonic glide
vehicle and 2) a Fractional Orbital Bombardment
System, or FOBS. This allows you to put a
hypersonic glide vehicle into a potentially
indefinite orbit around the earth. FOBS have
a lot of ins and outs. But the basic fear
surrounding them is simple. If your adversary
has a hypersonic missile in orbit, circling
the earth, you have no way of knowing when
or where it s going to come down.
GREGO: So that's orbital bombardment, but
why fractional? So fractional means you haven't
quite completed one go round to the Earth.
So each go round of the Earth takes about
90 minutes at these altitudes. And why do
you have to get out before you complete an
orbit? That is to make sure that you remain
in compliance with the Outer Space Treaty.
One of the core things in the Outer Space
Treaty is that you are not allowed to place
nuclear weapons into orbit, or station them
in space in any way. So it doesn't mean you
can't pop up and come down as an ICBM; that's
not being stationed, according to the Outer
Space Treaty. But putting them in orbit would
be contravening it. So there's a legal analysis
which suggests that as long as you don't complete
one entire orbit, you haven't contravened
your obligations of the Outer Space Treaty.
So it's fractional. So even if you dive down
at, whatever, 89 out of 90 minutes, that legal
analysis says that you still have respected
the Outer Space Treaty.
SIERRA: Wow. That is such a way to skirt around.
GREGO: Yeah. And I think a big thing about
the "no nukes and space" is that it truly
is meant so that we're not storing nuclear
weapons in space and just having another vector
of, "When might nuclear weapons rain down
on me?"
SIERRA: Right.
GREGO: So part of this of arming intercontinental
ballistic missiles with nuclear weapons is
that you can see them coming. And that is
stabilizing. You can not only see them coming,
but you can see them not coming. Every minute
we know that we're not being attacked with
nuclear weapons because we're looking for
them. But if you have nuclear weapons stationed
in space and they don't have the same signature
associated with nuclear weapons, that provides
another other thing we have to worry about
and be concerned about. So I think that that
provision of the Outer Space Treaty, whether
or not a FOBS contravenes it, it provides
a lot of useful stability.
SIERRA: Why do countries like Russia or China
want hypersonic missiles?
MOUNT: US adversaries have been pursuing an
across the board effort to defeat US missile
defenses. While the United States has its
missile defenses are aimed mostly at North
Korea. It used to also be against Iran. Russia
and China have been extremely alarmed, very
public and vocal about the risk that US missile
defenses could sometime someday in the future,
hold their arsenals at risk. The worry is
that the United States with its very capable
nuclear and conventional strike capabilities,
could conduct a first strike against, Chinese
or Russian capabilities and then use missile
defenses to mop up a retaliatory strike.
SIERRA: When talking about missile defense,
it s very important to distinguish between
the ability to detect incoming missiles, and
the ability to shoot them down. The U.S. is
very good at the detection part. Sensors on
land, sea and in space are constantly monitoring
for an attack. If a missile aimed at the U.S.
is detected, the U.S. military would launch
an interceptor to shoot the missile down.
This is where things get murky.
GREGO: So the United States fields currently
one system to defend the continental United
States from ICBMs, nuclear-armed ICBMs, it's
called the Ground-based Midcourse Defense
system. It's mostly interceptors based in
Alaska with a few in Vandenberg Air Force
Base in California, but they're meant to detect
an incoming intercontinental ballistic missile
from North Korea and destroy it before it
can get to the US. It does not work very well.
I mean, it's been decades of effort and tens
of billions of dollars, and it still has not
yet demonstrated capability even against sort
of the less sophisticated North Korean missiles.
SIERRA: But these limitations haven t stopped
countries like China and Russia from worrying
about U.S. missile defense.
GREGO: China and Russia are sort of looking
decades ahead, and if the United States manages
to make some kind of technological breakthrough,
or it decides to just invest in lots of different
systems for missile defense, they want to
be able to guarantee that their ability to
deliver nuclear weapons to the United States
is secure so that the deterrence relationship,
mutual assured destruction continues to be
the fact of the day.
SIERRA: It s worth pausing here, because mutually
assured destruction is a very important concept
when it comes to nuclear security. It s part
of a broader concept called deterrence.
SIERRA: So can you give us a quick refresher
on what nuclear deterrence means?
MOUNT: For any nuclear state, the basic requirement
of nuclear deterrence is that if your adversary
tries to wipe out your nuclear arsenal, you
still have the capability to inflict unacceptable
damage on them. The terms that we use to describe
this is that if, for example, the United States
with its extremely capable, conventional and
nuclear strike capabilities attempted to carry
out a first strike against Russia, China,
or North Korea, they want the ability to still
be able to retaliate, to still be able to
inflict unacceptable damage on the United
States and its allies.
SIERRA: The idea here is to make it so dangerous
to launch a nuclear weapon that nobody chooses
to do so. And while it might sound strange,
missile defense systems can make things more
dangerous.
MOUNT: If the United States missile defense
system could knock down or defend against
that smaller retaliatory strike package, then
it would undermine this basic requirement
of deterrence. It would mean that the United
States could wipe out an adversary's nuclear
arsenal and face no damage or no consequences
in return. For many years, the US missile
defense system has been relatively small and
aimed primarily at North Korea and also Iran.
Yet there has always been this wish in US
strategic circles to provide for perfect security,
to eliminate the vulnerability that the United
States has against its adversaries. So that
we're relying, not on deterrence, but on defense.
This was Ronald Reagan's wish. And it is a
wish that remains politically and emotionally
appealing today. It's what explains the US...
Continued US bipartisan investments in missile
defenses, even though they have had a very
mottled track record. So while US missile
defenses almost certainly do not have the
capability to defend against Russian, China,
North Korean second strike options, those
adversaries worry that it does. And there
are many in the US Congress and in the United
States that hope one day that it could, this
is what's driving this new arms race among
US adversaries to defeat, pierce or overwhelm
US missile defenses.
SIERRA: Many experts believe that deterrence
works best when everyone presents an equal
threat. But if one country pulls ahead, either
in offense or defense, the others must decide
how to keep up, and this can lead to an arms
race.
The Chinese test seemed to advance China s
side of the equation, and it came as a surprise
for people who assumed the United States would
always remain comfortably ahead of the game
in terms of missile technology.
SIERRA: So I heard this referred to as a Sputnik
moment. So what does that mean? And do you
actually agree with that analogy?
MOUNT: It's difficult to overstate the effect
that seeing Sputnik in the sky had on the
American psyche. It was a moment during the
Cold War where the United States realized
that it wasn't infallible.
SIERRA: For those who don t know, Sputnik
was the world s first satellite, and its successful
launch by the USSR in 1957 shocked the United
States, and spurred an intense technological
competition.
MOUNT: After World War 2, everyday people
realized that the Soviet Union was making
advances that could match or even exceed the
United States. It's difficult to see the same
level of impact from these Chinese test. One
reason is we don't in public know exactly
what was tested or its capabilities, but for
another it's surprising because China already
has the capability to hold the United States
at risk. It has very capable, Intercontinental
ballistic missiles at very long ranges. It's
building more of them. The United States has
been vulnerable to Chinese missiles for decades
now. So it's difficult to see why a new ability
to do that represents such a major tectonic
change
MOUNT: In our strategic environment, but it's
also not uncommon for US defense officials
to think this way.
GREGO:
China's nuclear arsenal is so much smaller
than the United States and Russia. And I know
you'll have heard that they're certainly growing
it and making it more sophisticated, but at
present it's much smaller than the US and
Russia's. So China's problem with the offense,
defense is more acute because then they can
imagine there might be more reality of the
United States striking them first and not
being vulnerable. I think that's one driver
of all of these exquisite systems.
SIERRA: China has roughly 350 nuclear warheads,
and is in the process of building new weapons
and missile silos. Of course that s just a
fraction of the 5,500 fielded by the United
States, but it s still a sufficient number
to present a credible threat to the US or
any other country.
MOUNT: The United States has been vulnerable
to its adversaries for decades and hypersonic
missiles don't change that. So this is less
of a story about new capabilities, and it's
more of a story about our discomfort with
the logic of deterrence. It is more of a story
about how the United States has never been
comfortable being vulnerable to its adversaries.
It's never been comfortable with the basic
bargain that it could deter an attack on the
United States. And, so throughout history,
the United States has looked for ways to overcome
that vulnerability.
SIERRA: Is the United States developing its
own hypersonic weapons?
MOUNT: Over the last decade especially, interest
in hypersonics has reached a fever pitch.
We are deeply concerned about the hypersonic
programs of adversaries, and we're engaged
in a crash program to develop our own. In
this enormous fervor around hypersonic glide
vehicles, nobody has stopped to ask the simple
question, what does the United States need
them for? US adversaries don't have ballistic
missile defense capabilities or cruise missile
defense capabilities that are as capable as
ours. And so the case for US hypersonic glide
vehicles is actually much weaker than that
for our adversaries. Yet the amount of money,
the, the amount of interest, the amount of
bureaucratic politics that is dedicated at
fielding, these systems as fast as possible
has been overwhelming. It's been irresistible,
but without an arms control arrangement for
hypersonic missiles, without any sense that
there would be reciprocal restraint on the
part of our adversaries. There's currently
not a major reason for the United States to
avoid developing these systems. And so they're
pursuing these capabilities full tilt.
GREGO: I'm concerned about overreaction. That
means we got to build more defenses, we got
to keep up with the Jones's, we have to build
our own of whatever they've got. And it incentivizes
this cycle, this arms race cycle, if you're
not careful. So if the United States thinks
missile defense is important and there's a
certain segment that thinks it's important
and might eventually work, you can't imagine
that it doesn't have any other effect in any
other country. And to be surprised when they
seek ways to come around it. Surprised when
they seek ways to counter it. I wouldn't overreact,
but I would look at it holistically and say,
this is a dynamic we need to really address.
It's very hard to admit that you are vulnerable
to anybody else. And there's a strong incentive
to make sure you can't be. And we're all on
the boat together. That's the way I see it.
I see it as a very, our security, of course,
can't come at the total expense of others
and they will work to address any way that
that happens. So we would be making the same
mistakes we made a generation ago.
GREGO: And I'm pretty concerned. We re handing
the keys to this complex, excessively dangerous
contraption to a next generation. It feels
very unfair to me. Lots of echoes of the climate
crisis. The same thing, like, boy, we've really
messed this up and here you go, good luck
kind of thing. I'm really concerned about
making this dangerous, complex thing just
self-continuing without really seeking all
the ways we can fix it, get rid of it.
SIERRA: And this is probably the most important
message to take from the fervor around hypersonics.
Yes, it is concerning that China appears to
have had a successful test. Yes, hypersonic
glide vehicles do add another layer of risk
to nuclear security. But the real danger has
been there all along - nuclear weapons themselves.
In the end, hypersonics are just a reminder
to the world about the fragile system of mutually
assured destruction that has saved us from
nuclear catastrophe.
GREGO: I don't think writ large human beings
can coexist with nuclear weapons indefinitely.
We cannot. They will be the end of us. So
we need to always be thinking of ways to make
them less important and less important. And
rather than more important, develop more complicated
delivery mechanisms to make things more challenging
for each other and to create this big complex
system, which is prone to mistakes and misunderstandings.
I think that's the wrong direction entirely.
So that's where I would create my concern.
It isn't hypersonic missiles are going to
change my everyday existence or I'm ready
for them to rain down on me. It's a symptom
rather than the disease. It's a symptom of
this commitment to nuclear weapons being important
and recapitalizing. So I would notice the
symptom and pay attention to
the disease.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes. Have a
question or some feedback? Just feel like
saying hi? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we d love it if you
could leave us a review. Ideally a good one,
the more stars the better. It really does
help us get noticed. Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy
Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our associate podcast producer. And I am
Natalia Lopez, this semester s podcast intern.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Claire Felter. Special thanks to CFR's visiting
military and intelligence fellows for providing
important background for this episode. Original
music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen. Additional
thanks to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke. For
Why It Matters, this is Natalia Lopez signing
off. See you soon!